so freute ich kann euch versprechen das
gamma hds in dieser folge nicht mehr
schaffen wird hier oben hinzukommen
außerdem freuen und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen app valentine special
dingsbums zusammen mit komme hd wir sind
hier gerade schon so ineinander verliebt
haben
oh ja immer doch heute sind wollen wir
hier nur liebe verteilen laves und dr
wie man auch schon den schönen fackeln
hier erkennen kann auf der karte denn
wir haben heute hier wieder von der app
einen texture pack gesponsert bekommen
nach dem motto und erstmal die erste
kiste hat man schwere nehmen endlich was
auf kollege wurden ja auch sonst ein
paar best ofs gemacht von den letzten
der letzten epic champion aber nicht
doch wo zb dourdan wo wir oben auf
diesem haus waren und an do so jetzt
muss ich aber die platte zu machen und
dann springst du trotzdem dagegen und so
was ich aber nicht also dann kann mir
auch nicht auf einmal den link nachher
kann man das besonders geil
bevor wir das hier starten mal wieder
das übliche abwechselnd hochladen
ich habe mir bei dir gelesen so viele
kommentare weil wir es nicht beim anfang
erwähnt haben die zweite folge wird bei
mir kommen und die dritte wir bei
kontrast und immer so weit also vierter
wird wer bei mir und fünfter wenn's da
eine fünfte geht bei ihm wieder genau
also alle ungeraden zahlen der mir
geraten bei ihm und dann jeden tag eine
folge bei mir dann wie eine echte kuh es
wichtig hier schön essen klang das schon
mal gut los
was haben wir eigentlich vollkommen fit
forever valentine's day for the world
routes ersten longplayer breaking locks
das ist klar
ok dann verkackt ok ok oh ja verdammt
wir haben so tiefer kann dann als
okay wir machen wollen wir hier
gemeinsam die regeln vorlesen kann
machen wir beide ok 3 2 play wilfried
software blade once restart minecraft
medien keine blankoschecks auch sehr
klug dass auf dem schild steht dass man
minecraft riis starten soll wenn die
schilder nicht angezeigt werden es gibt
ja wirklich viele leute die würden dann
wirklich gar nicht auf die idee kommen
jetzt irgendwie minecraft nochmal
neustadt die würden dann in walding
unter den trailer schreiben ja ne blöde
karte nicht gerade ein bin ich keine
lust und das geht so nicht okay was
haben wir hier du hast schon wieder
richtig viele schilder einfach mal
ausgenommen
ich habe mir das alles durchlebt damals
nur das typische typische letzten
wer den link von der tag vom von allen
von web und so in der beschreibung hier
hat uns dann dein kumpel noch viel spaß
könnte der 2020 kita oder vielen dank
dass ihr uns doch mal glück gewünscht
hast genau da aber das werden wir auch
brauchen
dann wollen wir mal schauen
nein schon mal ein kleiner berg schön
mit reddot gemacht dass geholt
schönheit hält sich der war so der berg
der wurzel hier rein generiert ich
glaube auch okay
und dann hätte ich schon ganz
schwierigen sprünge und das gemeinschaft
ohne deine hilfe
ich hab es auch geschafft hab ich bin
wieder runter gefallen wie ja gut hat
sich aber auch drauf kommen können
bezirk geschäft welches schon wieder
dahin dank der so eine schweinerei aber
auch aha
ich hab voll gelacht hörte da den
schalter tot
ok jetzt schaffe ich bin ihr gleitet
ohne kiste vielleicht mit den ersten
punkten mit den ersten punkten nein nur
mit fleisch schadet nur mit fleisch ich
habe immer noch rum
lass die mal hier die hälfte fleisch
oben in der kiste
ok neuen kann ich nicht teilen aber ich
lass dir trotzdem mal 45 in der kiste
und dann wieder runter aha ja ich werde
der jump weltmeisters hier wieder auf
dem weg ich war hier einfach mal auf
dich okay und danach ins register und
mit der rüstung kettenhemd und
heckenrose verdammt cool
ok wat wein doch vorbei gesprungen um
lästigen super ich bin gleich schon
wieder tote ach quatsch
dadurch habe ich bekommen habe keine
leben retten können weil die feder wie
jede folge jede staffel hier von der
picture web abgeschlossen werden in den
kommentaren
also kommt leute haut in die tasten und
gibt einen tipp ab wird er es schaffen
oder wird das stern so weit geschafft
er stimmt er kommt dann aber ich hab ein
schwert noch einmal schlagen nein
wirklich tot
du hast rüstung was sollen das
eigentlich bräuchte ich mir eine saftig
unterfalle hätten risse für den jockey
com gibt eine trasse und dann scheint
hier über und nicht darunter springen
nein nein nein
doch für mich nicht ich hoffe dass er
jetzt ich bin ja gut aber irgendwann
werde ich dann alles wieder in meiner
folge also hier zurückgeben
irgendwann dann etwas wenn das wäre zu
viel für mich ist das so ich habe es
geschafft
hätte regiert dann doch noch nicht
geschafft ich habe es geschafft doch bei
mir hat gerade ein bisschen der bei mir
auch deswegen hat das ding vertrag liegt
das in meiner leitung oder an deiner oma
ich glaube eher dass lacken des films
server weil wir uns mehr gehört ich hab
dich nicht gehört eben gerade so er denn
maximiert ok und da das schon geschafft
ok viel spaß
jetzt bin ich nicht mal wasser noch
gefallen für neben gesprungen als bei
bruch und drüber
so stand folge der mal wieder auf
schritt und tritt an der altersfrage
trendgetränke ohne ende und ich haben
wir anscheinend ein checkpoint noch ein
checkpoint geil
ok weitermachen wo achter obendrauf jump
boost verstehe die ganz schwierigen
sprünge wieder darum ist noch eine kiste
mit uns einfach mal versuchen allen
verdammt aber wir haben ja hier in check
point wo bleibst du hast und ich mache
mich jedoch über die springer löste
lustig karte ja die sprünge ganz
schwierig und ja so freunde ich kann
euch versprechen dass goma hds in dieser
folge nicht mehr schaffen wird hier oben
hinzukommen
wenn du da stehst schaffen das echt
nicht wo bist du ich bin ein schlimmster
feind kommt dass ich manchmal items
wieder haben ja muss zurückgehen durch
das ding ja genau ich probiere die
sprünge noch mal ich bin ja auch nicht
entschieden
ich habe mich nur mal etwas hier
beschleunigt durch den kleinen p ich bin
einer wir unter gesprungen und dann
schrieb er direkt hinter dir so ein
quatsch
der circa herzen in den augen ich habe
ich habe mehr angst vor dir als vom
körper ich habe mich liste gefunden
einer gas trainer höhe und ein helm
machen wir hier wie ein punkt der battle
doch nicht machen wir ja bald wird der
erste punkt gefunden hat ein moment ich
bin gleich wer oben alter das ist das
ist zum teil ist es ja geil
das gefällt mir jetzt war das spiel
richtig geil aus die ganze karte finde
ich war richtig cool auch bei der
letzten staffel
leider war es schon das dritte mal dass
wir so ein entwicklerkit machen ja und
die karte hier kam mir wirklich erst vor
ein paar tagen raus vorgehabt in dem
heute auf die kam vor etwa einer woche
ist genau von der woche ungefähr so
andere teams kaufte er ein genau und ich
bin ich auf dem baum drauf wo muss ich
lange davon ist der kiste ich bin hier
unten muss irgendwann doch rein springen
in der kiste war schon an der küste ich
finde den weg bestimmt noch du musst du
einfach noch an sonne leiter springen ja
geschafft ich hab's geschafft
da ist also
gumbo kursrutsch etwas haben wir hier
bestimmt wir irgendwelche fallen
mach du mal lieber vor wieder und ich
kann hier 14 gewinne sichern
wir werden auf jeden fall wenn wir im
bett geschlafen haben auch wieder dass
born
das ist gut denn da finde ich auch guck
mal ich hab's geschafft ist muss man
hören genau die sprünge die mag ich die
sind nicht wirklich schwer kann wirklich
jeder schaffen und die karte finde ich
trotzdem gut dass man kommt nicht
schlagen ich sehe ich dachte du willst
mir jetzt darunter schubs deswegen
checkpoint ruhm dass das schon mal gut
ja wunderbar wenn man davon gerade redet
so kann man hier hinter schade dachte
ich schon gut dann mal eben acht macht
und dann ab ins bett
ich komme nicht ins bett du bist das
bett meine wand wampe dreh dich schon
mal ein bisschen blockiere die hat alles
blockiert ihr so hatte hierzu schalter
ich habe abgenommen seit der letzten
folge für mich reicht mittlerweile in
der eigentlichen ich brauche dich zwei
betten
und fast geschafft das bisher wichtigste
was geht hier ab
dieser sprung verstärkung geil aber ich
war das texture pack erst recht weil ich
mit shader spiele
nein nein nein nein es sogar dann
hattest du gast drehen dann würde jeder
herspringen erhöre los springt hier den
schalter oder hinter dir einer wand
guter start schon mal aber du hast doch
der gast renault ja ich mache das jetzt
auch nicht gerade gespannt alles
geschafft hat es geschafft bin irgendwie
außerhalb des bohren sich auch mal das
klappt auch beim nächsten check points
go to the effects of the year edition ja
gerne immer doch alter oft er okay ich
hab's geschafft
aber wie komme ich hier wieder hoch hier
bin ich falsch
welche hoch kommt oder doch ich glaube
das ist richtig aber ich weiß nicht was
dann auch deshalb da vielleicht mal
etwas ist weil das liegt also die von
hier kommen wir ja schon wieder runter
wir unter leute wie ehrlich ich glaube
schon probleme aus geht man nach oben
nicht mal ganz kurz hier gucken weil
hier ist ja nichts mehr
das ist ja eine gastrede und du bist
einfach vorbei gekommen ist
dann war dieser ganze aufgaben hier nur
damit wir hier wieder raufkommen auf
zuspruch verstärkung dings a
man von ihr hier hoch und dann ihren
verstehe ok entscheide ich einfach raus
und fällt mir ruhig gleich gefragt warum
haben sie noch mal bei dem ein video von
dir alle in die kommentare geschrieben
gome ist so fasst wegen einer folie
verpackt in ein leuten wusste über alles
kaputt macht ich habe schalter gedrückt
meinen rollen fertig habt ihr leiter
bekommen geld im job in valverde war ich
hab' ich habe zwei ich habe zwei rails
school
das schafft man warte mal darüber
eigentlich springen schafften den sprung
schafft man die brauchen ja auch
eigentlich nur die leute brauchen aber
ich hab's ich hab's ich habe den sprung
auf die leiter auf jeden fall erstmal
geschafft so pass auf ich gehe auf die
leiter wir bauen hier einfach mal eben
uns schnell rüber mit dem eigenen
jablonec bild widmann und allein den
sprung schafft man glaube ich nicht oder
ich glaube schon
wir dürfen ja eigentlich keine blöcke
setzt und keine blöcke abbauen hilft ja
aber eigentlich
wir werden dann ja nicht weiterkommen
ich habe es geschafft was ein zufall
blue jahres erfordert die ecke was war
da eben auch noch auf den nächsten
sprung geholfen
ach ich weiß im internet obst das nicht
mehr jetzt bin ich millionen probe ich
hoffe du fällst du ja auch einfach
gleich mal schön runter jetzt einfach
mal komplett runter gefallen ich ja ich
hab's geschafft ja immer durch legale wo
ich bin schon viel weiter ich will es
eine kiste finden
eine ich bin schon viel weiter ich bin
von craft weil ich werde auch wenn du
dir junge schwert greenpeace bitte ich
muss meine kiste seine heute möchtest du
anscheinend immer das punktepaar ja ich
hab zwei gas alter das kann nicht sein
dann habe ich den 2 ich gucke in jedem
scheiß kiste eine bisher insgesamt ja
ich führe ja wohl klar für einen chat
und schuhe
ich habe zwei stück schon gucken jede
scheiße ist der letzte giro tour ein
kurzes was drin wie unfair das ist ich
bin gestorben ich bin noch kein einziges
mal gestorben bin richtig stolz auf mich
das kannst du auch da wo bleibst du
theoretisch immer aufs dach springt
nicht jetzt nichts
ich habe angst vor der höhe ab dann gehe
ich weg aber ich würde sagen dass war es
für den ersten paar zweite part ist bei
ghom hd morgen auf dem kanal können
einfach vorbeischauen oder die playlist
gucken oder redet ihr video antworten
von dem video hier genau und dann seht
ihr wie es hier weitergeht ich will dich
über dieser schallplatte gelaufen diese
druckplatte und ein ich auch nicht
machen wie in der nächsten folge
und dann schaut einfach wie es
weitergeht was die druckplatten machen
und ja mal schauen ich hoffe mal man
sitze ich wieder in der nächsten folge
haut rein und schön